Hyper Loops fliegende Autos autonom
fahrende Kleinbusse es gibt viele Ideen
für die Mobilität der Zukunft aber was
wäre wenn es schon längst ein
emissionsloses geräuschloses und
obendrein noch günstiges Verkehrsmittel
gibt das aber ein bisschen in
Vergessenheit geraten ist urbane
Seilbahnen scheinen das ideale
Verkehrsmittel zu sein also quasi
flugtaxis nur in gut okay aber weight
Seilbahnen im Ernst geht das überhaupt
komplett ohne Berge genau darum geht es
heute bei dr Watson
[Musik]
Seilbahnen mitten im Großstädten sind
keine neue Ideen schon vor knapp 50
Jahren entstand die Roosevelt Islands
tramway in New York und in den
Metropolen Südamerikas spannen sich
Ganze seilbahn-netze trotzdem gibt es in
Europa kaum Beispiele von Seilbahnen die
nicht ausschließlich touristisch genutzt
werden zum Beispiel im Wintersport ich
glaube er sagte gepriesen sind die
Skifahrer eine wirklich urbane Seilbahn
die auch in den ÖPNV Tarif integriert
ist gibt es in Deutschland einfach noch
nicht aber das soll sich jetzt ändern
wünscht sich sogar unser
Verkehrsminister denn sie sind
platzsparend sie sind kostengünstig sie
sind klimafreundlich und sie begeistern
Menschen wir sind auf jeden Fall
begeistert denn Seilbahnen haben eine
Menge Vorteile sie sind geräuscharmen
effizient schließlich muss der schwere
Motor in der Station nicht mit bewegt
werden sie sind CO2 neutral wenn sie mit
erneuerbaren Energien betrieben werden
und überfliegen sämtliche Hindernisse
aber das ist noch nicht alles die
Wartezeiten sind minimal die kabinenzahl
kann kurzfristig angepasst werden und
verglichen mit anderen Verkehrsmitteln
haben sie kurze Planungs- und Bauzeiten
die Bauarbeiten an der Seilbahn für die
Bundesgartenschau in Koblenz haben zum
Beispiel nur 14 Monate gedauert zum
Vergleich für eine U-Bahn können auch
mal gut und gerne zehn Jahre oder mehr
drauf gehen sie brauchen außerdem kaum
Personal und sind super effizient darum
sind die kostenverhältnismäßig niedrig
mit dreieinhalb bis 19 Millionen Euro
pro Kilometer sind Seilbahn günstiger
als Straßen oder U-Bahnen aber natürlich
teurer als eine Buslinie die keine neue
Infrastruktur benötigt aber brauchen wir
überhaupt noch ein neues Verkehrsmittel
also ich persönlich lebe ja in Köln und
kann ganz klar sagen ja alle fahren nur
Auto und keiner kommt irgendwo an aber
klar Köln ist flach und bei Seilbahn
denkt man natürlich irgendwie direkt
erstmal an eine Strecke von unten nach
oben aber das muss nicht sein
[Musik]
Seilbahnen lassen auch Flüsse und
Autobahnen Links oder eigentlich eher
unter sich liegen so könnten
abgeschnittene Stadtviertel leichter
erreicht werden ein krasses Beispiel ist
hier die gerade schon gezeigte Seilbahn
in Koblenz die die beiden Gebiete der
ehemaligen Bundesgartenschau verbindet
hier schwebt die Seilbahn fast einen
Kilometer ohne Stütze schräg über den
Rhein während ein Bus Shuttle 25 Minuten
für die Strecke gebraucht hätte schafft
es die Seilbahn in vier Minuten außerdem
können Seilbahnen als Bypass belastete
Straßen oder schienenabschnitte
überfliegen und wenn man mit den Öffis
raus aus der Stadt will fehlen oft
entweder radiale Anbindungen an die
Vorstädte oder tangentialverbindungen
dazwischen genau hier können Seilbahnen
ihre Stärke ausspielen Vorstädte
anbinden Lücken schließen
prinzipiell können mit Seilbahn sogar
komplexe Verkehrsnetz entwickelt werden
bei denen mehrere seilbahnlinien
miteinander verbunden werden wie zum
Beispiel zwischen La Paz und Alto und
das bringt etwas in Medien wurde durch
das seilbahnnetz die soziale Teilhabe
vieler Menschen in den Slums verbessert
das hat eine Studie herausgefunden die
ihr euch wie alle anderen unserer
Quellen auch unten in der
Videobeschreibung ansehen könnt das
Paypal konnte auch zeigen dass die
Anwohner sehr davon profitieren können
dass sie nun eine sichere und
verlässliche Möglichkeit haben von A
nach B zu kommen aber klar Seilbahnen
können mit ihren 20 bis 25 km/h nicht
mit U-Bahnen oder S-Bahnen mithalten
trotzdem wären sich Autos unten in der
Rush Hour im Schritttempo bewegen können
Seilbahnen einen Stau locker überfliegen
und wenn du mit den Öffis unterwegs bist
musst du im Herbst und Winter nicht mehr
den Fahrplan schicken das Seilbahnen bei
Schnee und Wind einiges ab können haben
sie schon seit Jahrzehnten bewiesen das
führt dazu dass sie letztlich schneller
sind zumindest auf Strecken von bis zu 7
km
trotzdem kann eine Seilbahn natürlich
keine U-Bahn ersetzen weil ihre
Förderleistung zu gering ist wenn eine
U-Bahn alle fünf Minuten fährt kann sie
9000 Personen pro Stunde in eine
Richtung transportieren Seilbahnen
schaffen je nach Bauart nur wenige
hundert bis maximal 4.000 Passagiere
aber das ist nicht unbedingt ein
Nachteil Verkehrssysteme haben halt
unterschiedliche Anforderungen an
unterschiedliche Strecken nicht auf
jeder Strecke gibt es ein so großes
Fahrgastaufkommen und nicht überall
lassen sich Tunnel oder Schienen bauen
und genau da haben Seilbahnen die Nase
vorn
fünf Minuten Pause
genau wie Verkehrssysteme haben auch wir
unterschiedliche Anforderungen an unsere
Ernährung mir persönlich ist es zum
Beispiel wichtig auch bei wenig Zeit
ausgewogen und proteinreich zu essen und
nicht irgendein Fastfood wenn wir hier
dr Watson drehen dann schaffe ich es oft
leider nicht großartig zu kochen und da
ist wifood echt eine gute Option
[Musik]
ich trinke WiFi tatsächlich schon seit
einigen Jahren und deswegen sind wir
auch zugegangen um eine Kooperation
vorzuschlagen denn ich muss sagen ich
bin's wirklich mega lecker das sind
außerdem alle wichtigen Nährstoffe drin
die man so in einer Mahlzeit braucht und
dazu ist noch Laktose und glutenfrei und
ich muss mir keine großen Gedanken um
Kochen Einkaufen abspülen und alles
mögliche machen meine Lieblingsorten
sind tropical oder Schokolade classic
Schoko die schmeckt mir von allen
trinkbaren Mahlzeiten da draußen
tatsächlich am besten
auch mal ausprobieren wollt dann schaut
unter dem Link in der Videobeschreibung
auf der Website vorbei oder gibt den
Code Watson - Youtube ein dann bekommt
ihr 10% Rabatt auf alles im Store und
jetzt geht's weiter
okay wo waren wir noch mal ach ja der
Einsatz von Seilbahnen in der Stadt
warum gibt es denn jetzt noch keine in
Deutschland wenn die doch so toll sind
obwohl in schon vielen Städten darüber
gesprochen wurde Berlin München
Köln-Bonn Düsseldorf Konstanz the list
goes on wurde noch keine gebaut
zumindest keine die nicht rein
touristisch genutzt wird warum könnte
man da doch fragen nun das ist ein
bisschen so wie bei den windtrailern
eigentlich sind alle dafür aber sobald
eine konkrete Planung im Raum steht
schlägt die positive Stimmung um in
Umfragen sind zwar vier von fünf
Befragten für urbane Seilbahnen aber
fast genauso viele wollen sie auch nicht
vor der eigenen Haustür haben darum
müssen durch Diskussionen Simulationen
und transparente Infos die betroffenen
Gruppen eingebunden werden Stichwort
Bürgerbeteiligung
auch individuelle Bedenken wegen der
Sicherheit und der eigenen Privatsphäre
Platz oder Höhenangst spielen hier mit
rein
seilbahnkabinen mit privacy glass
könnten einige Kritikpunkte lösen aber
nicht alles lässt sich so leicht Regeln
warum werden für neue Autobahnen immer
wieder Leute enteignet während
seilbahnprojekte wegen seilbahngegnern
verworfen werden darf man private
Grundstücke überfliegen und wie bindet
man kritische Stimmen ein das wirft
Fragen über den Stellenwert von
einzelnen in der Gesellschaft auf die
gar nicht so leicht zu beantworten sind
[Musik]
also werden Seilbahnen jetzt unsere
Städte erobern nun fest steht sie hätten
auf jeden Fall ihre Berechtigung in
unseren verkehrsnetzen gerade wenn es um
die Überquerung von Hindernissen geht
sind sie oft effizienter als andere
Verkehrsmittel
Zwischenstationen verlangsamen den
Betrieb daher sind sie also vor allem
für Punkt zu punktverbindungen von
wenigen Kilometern geeignet in den
künftigen Ausschreibungen im ÖPNV werden
Seilbahnen hoffentlich endlich mehr als
Alternative berücksichtigt in
Deutschland brauchen wir endlich mal
eine urbane Seilbahn die nicht nur
geplant wird sondern auch tatsächlich
mal fährt Experten haben uns gesagt wenn
in Deutschland noch ein paar Projekte
verworfen werden dann ist das Thema hier
verbrannt hier hakt es oft an lokalen
Widerstand obwohl es in anderen Ländern
echte Leuchtturmprojekte gibt und das
ist spannend irgendwie sind Seilbahnen
ja total verstaubte Technik irgendwie
aber auch echt innovativ wodurch sich
ganz neue gesellschaftliche Probleme
ergeben wie immer vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig
Bundesgartenschau